what's up guys I'm Josh Thole Yosef I'm
Nora David and we're about to check out
Marvel's Avengers gameplay footage are
you ready I forgot my popcorn and my
soda
we need your popcorn yeah would be great
man all right guys let's check it out
let's check it out
Cisco Bay Area never meet your heroes
who thinks talking right now
Wow Tony check it out once thought to
check it out the Norse god of thunder
the entire bridge is exploding cops got
there let's be fun you deal with this
wall let's go on his face a mountain in
the open old cattle cattle sack open
triangle push that triangle oh my god
John's done yeah oh my god you think
this Matt's gonna save you he's juggling
him in the air that's fire oh look at
that and you can do combo look at these
combos yes I love how the cops know well
that's a brother he knows a man oh and
then you get well you can just punch
without in there that's fire this is
good oh this is really really really
good turn the back baby the notion but
hey we're still pushing up that's fire
yeah I got so much noise you guys say
the civilians
oh my G is so Thor so Thor lucky for you
I might see you Leila whatever Oh comes
right back yeah oh I love house whole
body just lights up like that yeah I'm
like a pile gonna keep us flying right
there these guys think they have a
chance this is beautiful
look at California Republic flag in the
back just flying I love I love the
detail in the back oh my god and it
looks like you get like maybe another
ability on the here comes Iron Man nice
like a little l1 r1 right here on the
bottom right like different different
specials or abilities they look so right
here you can press R r1 right here in
the corner I wonder if that's the Super
Bowl hey impress Ian and your health bar
things on the top yeah I want to just
get my hands on this like oh look at
this still triumph yeah right there's
something like there's like charging up
a pro yeah
yo distractive nice I can do it just all
the night so you could say the turkey
stuffing cranberry sauce and I love how
he has like dialogue throughout here's
an Iron Man just in it Iron Man coins
chill would have it fly oh okay
upgrading upgrading villains here we go
enemy types out nice
oK you've got that now you can go up and
down left right I wonder if you can
switch back to Thor but no it's like
it's just interactive you just like now
your eyes fluid that's great
looting that civilians are right
underneath running away from you that's
amazing game design because a lot of
people could just be like no we want to
make it simple it's too much already but
this is great I picked it off it's just
such great gameplay like great character
capture because like Tony's always
talked about he's actually fighting
I can't fight and talk ok bye like New
York you know obviously New York is
super big in Marvel yeah now we have San
Francisco yeah got the Bay Area it's
exploded and now we have the West Coast
represent very detail which is great
balance I wonder if I he can do all the
lot Ames what is this
oh I love how everyone has different
fighting mechanics fighting style
yeah like Thor's like all like hammering
tality Iron Man's like repulsors mm-hmm
and tech this is fire oh he's locked on
that's so cool
yeah use that beam again this fire sell
out me on it now security protocols the
chimeras autopilot is taking over smells
like a heist we're heading back you're
up Bruce oh here we go
feels like I have to do this do this
here we go my man just gets angry why he
jumps off shows up once oh I never get
this close back like always think some
of it throws it around
oh man shucks man whoa Oh smash yeah
it's just smash thank you everything I
ever wanted
oh yeah see you later throw up [ __ ]
that's what we do all day just pick you
up and throw them throw them off the
bridge bodies Wow
destroy the tag no doubt he's running
through card I do baby
nice boom God see you later
it's Park org I love how hope like they
have speechless hope he just grunts and
just smashes everybody else is talking
around him look if he catches a plane
I'm done
oh yes the floor yeah well that bridge
ain't never be a do every that's that
he's like six feet taller than everyone
which is awesome type of game that you
turn on your friends are like what are
you playing right now what yeah and they
just are captivated by yeah yeah I'm
just huh guy just picked up a bridge
hitting people with it like yo you want
corners like Marvel's Avengers
I'm already over right now like put it
up I can watch this all day as beautif
there's no more bridge the bridge is
true Logan he grabbed him to the wall
and just like you said just parks horn
through the bridge San Francisco needs
years alright the RMP bridge though oh
but that ain't that ain't the whole
quote knows all the way out trying to be
enemies oh nice going down I think I
mean that's talking to can you guys just
100 he's using a special that's a
special move yeah so that's a special
move in the tough about it right there
is yes I'm with the whole tank
wow it kicks in with his big toe cutie
puny are two songs chambers tank
explosion
was like thanks for doing all the work
I'm right here they have such a killer
cast for the power boys acting seems
like the reactors malfunctioning oh yeah
New York accent I like that I like that
New York accent hey keV America I see
you you go count America time
uh it's all for overcast so good cap cap
yeah there come on mr. America pull up
oh man you can really feel that action
look look how fast he recovers when I
fight I hate it because he's superhuman
how many times you could throw the shell
at what control that is do you have like
a meter
yeah they look so like his meter right
there of this year yeah bottom part so
let him write his combos man ladies
charging it up uh-huh just he can take
it he can kick his shell back into a
person that's insane
damn yeah you can block and absorb oh
that's what he did Iron Man Civil War
shield to the freakin pissed I just want
to see like an after credits I'm
everywhere just like it crunches get him
up be like well we didn't win this oh
okay so his special is like all around
him flipping over she'll be there man I
always feel so patriotic when he fights
so proud of this country every time you
fight I'm like you know what yeah the
ship's finest response was attacking the
ship they're helping her up you just
fell prop that can't be I mean the shirt
in the backpack yeah Easter Egg here we
go I'm so excited cave team's name
correctly mastered the ultimate badass
your skull mask I mean it's like there
you go little salt little sprinkle on
top some sprinkles on your ice cream he
just learned from your fighting style so
he can yeah replicated by
oh no no oh oh nice out here where's
after he destroyed it
that's Hulk classic oh I know I
destroyed it but let me save a little
piece I want to replace Black Widow oh
yeah that's what I know yes let's do
Tasha
now there's parkour with Natasha
yeah now hey Zack get them get them
aside like kids they get to grow up with
this yeah playing on like pixelated
graves integrate this what oh oh my god
oh my god yeah this is yeah this is what
we wanted just play them all and
everything those gives me a fork a story
yeah that's it
you got me the second time oh you can
fill them in bong
okay black will oh I love that everybody
has their own individual fight it's not
confusing you know
oh here we go let's see
boom you're even moving though he's not
even moving out he's tough so you can
play your pistols and go hand-to-hand
okay that's good that's fine I chose
your ammo on the side that's no longer
super move is oh it was like a movie man
yes there you go they're just a grapple
okay Stone the shield I handed the sword
and shield jump up and smash down yeah
oh yes yes let me get right to a movie
what that was that we didn't you do some
bomb yeah their gather did she look like
if she goes in those areas they'll blow
up this is literally a boss fight right
now I want to play
I didn't even Lego get to control the
fav how does work control the controller
please oh my god beautiful yes Oh get in
there oh it's been stored away
oh she's coming you're taxing at me bro
just in the background you can adapt to
this yes shock them nice
oh damn what a fight get it
Natasha become Thor way to go way to go
see nobody else you don't understand how
we just went from white we started with
Thor start with Thor Iron Man Hulk
Captain America Black Widow hello and I
won in the gameplay does it go like rito
does it go back to the beginning of that
this has been like what maybe like 15
minutes and you've already played as all
by 505 Avengers yes Wow
nobody are you sure are you sure about
that
some say they were set up okay so the
voice in the future like time travel
he's dead he's died told you was oh my
god he died have died kept be killed
what this is domination nice in space
that's insane that's insane that's
insane that's insane
attitude oh man
Oh Nora what do you make of that
speechless men it's like everything we
always wanted like I've been saying to
the gameplay like now we have all five
Avengers and we and details of the big
air in the West Coast it's it's
phenomenal man that's that's gonna be
things people gonna play over and over
and over and over again how you feel
about it yeah man you shot right yeah
yeah if you showed this trailer to my
five-year-old self he said when you're
when you get older this is a game you
will play doesn't exist I'll never exist
in the world I am I'm speed I'm like you
speechless I'm blown away you can throw
a hammer bring it back Hulk smash the
floor repulsor ray out of the chest
chest interactive press triangle they
dodged president park horn through the
bridge it's and the whole Bay arrogance
represented a whole West Coast workers
gonna lose business you work it's gonna
be tumbleweed on the streets everybody's
inside just playing it man everybody man
even grandparents grandparents you got
there your grandma you guys see this
guy's I'm spent we just watched Marvel's
Avengers gameplay and it's fire and it
comes out May 15 2020 it's gonna be
available on PlayStation Xbox Stadium PC
I'm dead and definitely keep watching
marvel for more details on that
this is Marvel your universe